okay so um to start why don't you tell
for my audience that doesn't know tell
them what is red pill content
okay the red pill is simple the red pill
is the answer the red pill is the
solution to feminism it's a combination
of a solution to feminism combined with
the way women really operate these days
most men grow up thinking that women
operate one way but in actuality they
operate another way and even though
there are countless men who have
experienced
these contradictions in terms of what
we're told versus what we see the vast
majority of men still either can't or
won't
uh
allow themselves to subscribe to the
fact that hey
these women are not they're not they're
not our grandmothers they're not
really not really our grandma they're
not our ancestors women operate now in a
certain way and the thing is pearl is
that women have men and women have
always been the same it's really the
environment that's changed women have
always been hypergamous there are women
have always been hope pergamos as well
it's just that now with the globalized
sexual marketplace and of course the
advent of the smartphone women now have
access to all the sausage they want and
their smartphones allow them to hide it
so again just to sort of wrap things up
the red pill and red pill content is
just telling guys hey this is what
you're told we're going to tell you guys
what you've been told is a lie this is
this is the truth this is how this is
the solution to feminism that's really
all it is so can i have an example of
something that is blue pill and how you
would fix it with red pill
yeah so for example um a lot of guys
there are
dead bedrooms a lot of men um
they um they say oh you know i've i've
i'm i'm married and i haven't had sex
with my wife in three months that is a
quote-unquote blue pill relationship now
if the if the man is not upholding his
end of the bargain let's say he lost his
job he got fat
he stopped caring he's you know gambling
and all that good stuff okay that's fine
i understand that interestingly enough
those kinds of men tend to have the most
success with modern women but taking it
back to what we're talking about now is
if you're a man and you're not upholding
you're into the bargain then you don't
deserve a woman to be right or die for
you but in most cases as far as
relationships and marriages are
concerned the man is upholding his end
of the bargain he's the he is the
breadwinner he takes care of the kids
he's good to his wife he doesn't he
doesn't he doesn't run around on his
wife a lot of people think that's a bad
thing to do
but in return they're not being rewarded
for their loyalty towards their women
they're actually being punished and so
the
so the the red pill solution to that is
number one
make sure you select a woman who is on
your program and number two make sure
you keep your value high no that doesn't
guarantee anything you can keep your
value high and do everything the red
pill the right way and the [ __ ] can
still go wrong women can and will leave
you for any reason or no reason at all
at any time that's just that's just how
it is there are no guarantees in life
but the red pill seeks to increase the
odds of success with women without them
taking your pound of flesh
and tell me do you think that feminism
is contributing to the crazy high
standards that we see from women today
oh yeah of course of course um
and look
women can have women can have high
standards
and people are entitled to having
whatever standards they want unless
you're 300 pounds
listen if you're 300 if you're a 300
pound woman and you want a man with a
six-pack abs a six-foot dick and you
know a six car garage who's making six
figures fine if that's what you want
that's cool
is it likely that you're going to get
that as a 300 pound woman no it's
possible but highly unlikely so and and
feminism
has told women that they can have it all
feminism has told women if you act like
a man you will get the man of your
dreams if you're a boss babe uh if you
get your degree if you make a lot of
money you're gonna get the man of your
dreams the 666 guy um but women even
though there is so much empirical data
so many
anecdotes from around the world
people can see that it's not working but
they're still they they still have these
ridiculous standards so that's where we
are right now
okay so then my next question is
how
do you have a red pill relationship what
is the difference between a relationship
that is red pilled and one that is you
know like the traditional i don't even
want to say traditional like a modern
relationship
um i'll let deb go first on this
i'll go i'll go first and then and then
i'll let you i'll let you go first and
then i'll then then i'll go after you
i don't want to i don't want to suck the
air out of the room
you stuck there oh me no i mean i have
no idea what you're talking about um
let's see i think our relationship is um
is different because there are
there are set expectations there are set
boundaries and there are
uh there's a mutual respect as far as
what our roles are in this relationship
um
you know you know
what what brought me to the red pill was
that was learning that the the narrative
that we're taught
um doesn't match the reality so like the
whole happy wife happy life type of
thing you know and prioritizing the
women's happiness over the happiness of
men
it doesn't equate to a happy
relationship in the long run um better
it's to be said um like happy spouse
happy house where you know both people
are are are benefiting from the
relationship and you know are are happy
you know it's really all anybody wants
us to be happy
so um
for calling this a red pill relationship
i would say
um
we both stay in our lane we don't try to
take over one another's role one
another's job um we communicate
effectively
uh we
respect one another to the point where
okay you know if i trust that he's going
to say what he's going to do
and he's trusting that i'm doing what
i'm saying and not only that i have i
offer the proof to back it up um so what
we one of the things that i think sets
us apart from other couples is that we
uh we close the the margin for cheating
um which is
something that a lot of couples just
either choose not to pay attention to
or we just accept this thing as normal
um you know girls you know
taken women being uh on social media
posting as if they don't have a marriage
or a relationship to protect
um you have women going to you know
going out the girls nights out doing
vegas trips acting like they're single
when really they have a family at home
that they need to protect women aren't
really being held
well let me put it this way
women have this entitlement that they
they expect they deserve the best they
want the best um and it's it's the world
is their oyster but they lack any
accountability as to
how why what when where it's just the
magically be manifested um
if we think about it it will happen if
we wish for it it'll come true um no
relationships take a lot of work
and uh to have a healthy one to have a
happy one where both people are as
equally happy you really need to put in
the groundwork early and i think that's
one thing that set us apart from most
relationships we didn't just come
together and then figure it out over
time he knew what he wanted out of
things i knew what
didn't work put it that way and i was
looking for guidance and saying hey
what we've been told it doesn't work so
i obviously need to find someone who i
can follow their lead and who is going
to show me a different way that can
ultimately lead to happiness and we've
been five years strong at this point